as for this former late night host Jay
Leno he's showing off his new face after
being set on fire to all third degree
burns it's a great way to lose weight
first you you burn off the calories then
you're going to crash diet on your
motorcycle and you and I dropped 20
pounds and the facts that I have
smoother skin powdery lips and a tighter
butt has nothing to do with being in the
hospital cracking jokes on the Kelly
Clarkson show today less than four
months after the accident Jay revealed
something else new that's a brand new
ear it's a new ear what
y'all are incredible I'm gonna get to
that
Leno's medical team also revealed the 72
year old delayed treatment he was like
all right I got to get home to my wife
and we're like no no you have to stay
and what get admitted you left
well because my wife didn't know
anything about what was going on and and
I I wanted I wanted to reassure her so I
went home first then I came back the
next morning so this is why even that's
how you stay married 40 years yeah yeah
and we have another health update this
one revealing why Hoda copy has been
absent from The Today Show for eight
days the code is okay she's got a family
health matter that she's been dealing
with so we look forward to seeing Huda
and Savannah back here at the desk very
very soon meanwhile Ed Sheeran just
shared his and wife Cherry seaborn's
private struggle last year saying quote
my pregnant wife had a tumor with no
route to treatment until after the birth
in a handwritten note the singer just
announced his new album and detailed his
turbulent in 2022. this message just
keeps us depressed we forget that we're
here right from caring for Cherry after
daughter number two was born to reeling
from his best friend's death Ed says he
channeled his fear depression and
anxiety into subtract scrapping a decade
of work to rewrite all the album songs
in just one week and made this
announcement today I'm basically coming
back and I'm going to do a mini tour to
launch the first single from subtracts
lots of love
and there is big news for Kobe Bryant's
Widow Vanessa she scored a huge victory
in court getting more than 28 million
dollars
this after settling her 2020 lawsuit
against L.A County's First Responders
who shared graphic images of the victims
killed in the helicopter crash the 28.85
million dollar amount includes the 15
million that was awarded last summer to
Vanessa and her three surviving
daughters all grateful for their mom's
support just being able to rely on each
other and be there for each other has
been like the biggest inspiration